et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec jean paul hamon médecin généraliste
président de la fédération des médecins
de france jean paul hamon bonjour en aux
deux présidents d'honneur dont l'odeur
monge en tout cas merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors le kobe 19
aurait fait moins de morts qu annoncée
par le gouvernement c'est en tout cas ce
que révèle cette étude de santé publique
france qu'en pensez vous écoutez je ne
pense rien ce sont ce sont des personnes
qui sont décédées points
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu notamment j'ai un
exemple proche de moi dans ma patientèle
une personne qui a été effectivement
contaminés mais qui étaient au stade
terminal de la maladie elle est
peut-être une dizaine de jours devant
elle au maximum elle est décédée
elles étaient contaminés mais c'est pas
le commis de 19 qui l'a fait
malheureusement elle était malade bien
avant donc effectivement si on
comptabilise comme ça on se rend bien
compte que il ya forcément eu des cas
attribués aux comics 19 sa change rien
au fait qu'ils soient morts et et il ça
change rien aux problèmes que nous avons
rencontrés lors de cette épidémie c'est
à dire une des organisations sanitaires
et une absence de réactivité
d'administration points est-ce que entre
temps vous pensez que voilà on s'est un
peu mieux organisées
si aujourd'hui il ya une deuxième vague
c'est une crainte qui est en tout cas
présente le système hospitalier
notamment le système dans l'est dans les
ehpad est prêt écoutez vous je vois que
vous aussi vous me parlez pas de la
médecine de vide le ségur de la santé a
complètement oublié la médecine de ville
or qu'est-ce qui a fait que ce système a
été complètement désorganisée c'est que
l'on s'est pas appuyé sur la bêtise de
vite sur les médecins de premier recours
on ya pensé seulement au bout de deux
mois quand il a fallu déclarer les cas à
la caisse d'assurance maladie pour
identifier les contacts pour que les les
services de l'assurance maladie qui
identifie les contacts on n'a pas
protégé la médecine de premier recours
et il ya eu cinq mille cinq cents
médecins est contaminée et 46 décès de
médecins sur les 51 décès qu'on a
répertorié il faut s'appuyer sur la
médecine de ville
et si il n'y
de nouveau une flambée de l'épidémie en
octobre comme c'est comme c'est
malheureusement prévisible il va falloir
que les médecins généralistes des
infirmières libérales soient équipés
pour pouvoir tester les gens
symptomatique pour pouvoir identifier
les cas contacts et circonscrire la
maladie parce que le problème qui va se
passer en octobre c'est qu' il n'y aura
pas que le coc vide à circuler il y aura
également la la grippe ignore également
les vrs etc
tous les virus respiratoires vont
circuler il va falloir faire la
différence si on veut pas confiné
l'ensemble de la population
voilà ce qu'il faut faire il faut
s'organiser dès maintenant il s'appuyer
sur la médecine de ville on voit un
ségur de la santé qui a investi sur
l'hôpital c'est une bonne chose mais
investir sur l'hôpital sans investir sur
de médecine de ville
c'est continuer à creuser le déficit de
la sécurité sociale sans trouver de
solution voilà ce que ce qu'il faut
faire
sagan ise en testant massivement la
population via justement à ces médecins
de ville il ya aujourd'hui aussi le port
du masque qui est désormais obligatoire
dans tous les espaces clos qui
accueillent du public est ce que cette
mesure peut vraiment freiner l'épidémie
mais c'est utile c'est une bonne chose
c'est une excellente chose mais il faut
avoir dans sa poche un petit flacon de
gel hydroalcoolique et se lavaient les
mains dès qu'on touche son masque sinon
ça sert à rien porter un masque parce
que le masque on le touche sans arrêt et
si vous avez touché votre masque la
chose la plus simple c'est de se laver
les mains derrière parce que en touchant
votre masque que vous racontez mines et
vos mains donc ce sont des choses qu'il
faut expliquer tranquillement c'est pas
la peine de jeter son masque comme on
voit actuellement le masque il peut
servir en ville le mas qui peut servir
plus de quatre heures vous n'êtes pas
dans un bloc opératoire
donc le masque que si nous en prenez
soin vous pouvez le garder et toute la
journée parce que vous l'avez pas toute
la journée sur le nez vous n'êtes pas
toute la journée dans des magasins dans
des lieux clos vous pouvez être chez
vous vous pouvez être dans des lieux où
ouvert donc il faut prendre soin de son
bras et se laver les mains après avoir
touché voilà mais c'est une balle un
constat conserver les gestes barrière se
laver les mains et le et le gel
hydroalcoolique une dernière question
voit que le tourisme reprend au fur et à
mesure en france
on s'est aperçus dans les aéroports
jusqu'à maintenant il n'y a toujours pas
de tests obligatoires
en tout cas pour les passagers en
provenance de pays hors heureux hors
union européenne qui sont jugés
officiellement à risque ce que cela vous
inquiète
ben c'est inquiétant et on a bien vu que
le redémarrage dans la région de
marseille est dû au fait de l'arrivée de
deux personnes qui viennent de pays qui
ne sont pas contrôlés
ça c'est une anomalie c'est une anomalie
majeure de de circulation au moins il
faudrait identifier les gens quand ils
arrivent les tester et pouvoir les
retrouver
il est clair que là la libre circulation
de la population venant également de
payer affecté est une chose qui est un
petit peu inquiétante et qui a fait la
preuve à marseille que qu'il fallait
contrôler ses entrées merci beaucoup en
tout cas jean paul hamon d'avoir réagi
sur notre antenne ce matin je rappelle
que vous êtes médecin généraliste
président d'honneur de la fédération des
médecins de france